c'est un scandale sans précédent dans la
communauté scientifique et médicale le
sud coréen hwang haut ce que l'homme qui
pour la première fois avait produit des
embryons humains clown est une prouesse
controversé mais qui donne l espoir à de
nombreux malades et qui pourraient être
soignés par des cellules souches
seulement voilà l'équipe du chercheur
aurait triché
les explications de nicolas ce tout neuf
les visages sont fermés et pour cause il
y encore quelques semaines le professeur
hwang woo suk était un scientifique
adulé par son pays la corée du sud
aujourd'hui c'est un paria que ces
quelques étudiants les plus fidèles
doivent protéger des caméras lorsqu'il
sort une dernière fois de son université
je présente mes plus sincères excuses à
ceux que j'ai déçu ou choquer j'ai donc
décidé de démissionner de mon poste de
professeur à l'université de séoul une
chute vertigineuse à la mesure des
immenses espoirs que l'homme avait
suscité dans le domaine du clonage
thérapeutique
en mai dernier le dr huang publié un
article annonçant pour la première fois
l'extraction par son équipe de
nombreuses lignées de cellules souches à
partir d'un embryon humain clown est un
pas gigantesque vers le clonage
thérapeutique et le traitement de
maladies comme le diabète ou celle
d'alzheimer
mais voilà une commission d' enquête a
révélé à la presse plusieurs
falsification de photos et du résultat
les données de l'article publié dans
science ne pas fait le résultat d'une
simple erreur mais sont issus d'une
manipulation délibérée
l'objectif c'est de faire croire à
l'existence de onze lignées de cellules
souches au lieu de deux le dr hwang
reste un éminent spécialiste du clonage
d'animaux il est ainsi le seul à avoir
réussi à cloner un chien quant à ses
travaux sur le clonage humain il faudra
encore de nombreuses vérifications pour
séparer le vrai du faux